Has tenido la "Minimum Edition" en tus manos estas últimas 48 horas,
y ya has sentido el poder real del Trap Score en tu operativa.
Ya sabes lo que es operar con un escudo protector,
pero mientras tú solo vigilas el puntaje,
las "ballenas" ya están evolucionando para manipular el mercado.
La versión gratuita solo te muestra la puerta de salida,
pero el protocolo completo te permite ver toda la habitación.
Ahora mismo, solo estás viendo la mitad de la historia.
Los algoritmos institucionales están lanzando señales falsas
diseñadas específicamente para disparar tu ansiedad y el FOMO.
Cuando la trampa se cierra, un escudo básico no será suficiente.
Necesitas el poder total de nuestra suite de inteligencia visual.
Cuatro motores de IA (Grok, GPT, Gemini y CryptoQuant)
trabajando en sincronía absoluta para ti.
Rastreo de ballenas en tiempo real, filtros de sentimiento,
y toma de decisiones en 3 segundos. Esto no es solo trading,
es tomar una "ventaja injusta" sobre el resto del mercado.
Para celebrar a nuestros nuevos defensores, abrimos la campaña.
Solo para las próximas 50 personas que actúen ahora,
pueden desbloquear todo el sistema con un 50% de descuento.
Protección institucional completa por menos de un dólar al día.
Pero atención: una vez se llenen los 50 cupos,
este enlace expirará y el precio se duplicará de inmediato.
No dejes tu capital a merced de la suerte o el azar.
Es hora de mejorar tu protocolo de defensa profesional.
Usa el código "defend 50" en el checkout ahora mismo.
Bienvenido a la academia completa.
Vamos a conquistar el mercado juntos.
Asegura tu ventaja ahora.
Ganemos esta batalla.